[Applause]
I did not enjoy the arrow
tour that doesn't mean that it was a bad
movie it's me hi I'm the
problem it's
me welcome to the a
tour I'm not a Swifty but it's not
Taylor Swift's fault it's not the
producer's fault production was very
very high quality I am not a white girl
I'm a slightly sarey man and so this
movie was not for me the ARs tour was
not for me Taylor Swift is not for me
but that doesn't mean that it's bad I've
decided I need a rubric to really make
clear where these movies fall and so
there going to be two axes on the rubric
there's going to be the Epic to
extremely Lan kind of axis and then
there's going to be the uh super lib to
Super traditional axis we'll go from 0
to 10 0 to 10 in both axes so if it's
really epic and really traditional
that's a movie like The Godfather say or
the passion or I don't know Braveheart
if a movie is really lib and really bad
that's a movie like the female
Ghostbusters the like the writing's not
great the casting was obviously insane
and the message is bad so an example of
of a a movie in the top left quadrant so
you're talking about a movie that has
very good production value it's
competently made but it's just the idea
animating it is so bad and dumb maybe
like American Beauty that would be there
and then what's a movie that is right
about things but
is like maybe somewhat hastily made or
well an example of look I I would never
say this but as I was sitting with Mr
Davies he he he said it wasn't me he
suggested that maybe some of the films
that he has been in which have the right
message and idea but they've been a
little bit sometimes a little Slimmer on
the budget and the it's not always the
most to so
maybe some of those movies would go into
that wad again that's not my opinion
that's Mr Davis's so that those are the
kind of differences there where does
this movie land it
lands right in the
center actually leans a little bit Trad
on
ideology no matter I don't know if
Taylor Swift votes for Democrats or not
but the the whole idea of it is is
pretty traditional actually so it's it's
one even maybe two on the traditional
side and then on the Film Production
side it's almost a perfect score it just
was filmed so well for a concert so
maybe a a nine so you go up there that's
a nine then you go over here that's a
about a six or even a seven so that's 15
out of 20 75% you'd think 75% is bad but
I don't know three out of four stars
it's pretty good it's not bad it's a
solid
C
but it's not for me I found it deeply
unpleasant to actually sit there and
watch the movie because it was even just
kind of creepy I'm I'm a guy I'm a
single guy going into a movie theater
they didn't even have popcorn at the
theater so I'm the weirdo sitting in the
theater with just an unsweetened iced
tea surrounded by Millennial women and
some teenage girls and it's it was weird
but I'm there I'm watching it I I wanted
to to chime in on this pop cultural
phenomenon that's netted what $100
million at the box office dominates box
office sales this is after the era's
live tour made Taylor Swift a
billionaire are what the hell is this
all about and I got my answer right from
the beginning of the movie Taylor comes
out and she starts talking to the
audience like a friend says oh you're my
soulmates I'm so glad we get to hang out
together and just I get to be here with
you she's pointing at the audience and
they love her they eat her up and it's a
little bit contrived the kind of winking
on the stage cuz she's playing to a a
stadium of like a bazillion people but I
think a lot of the reason people like
her is it's a parasocial relationship
it's not just about the music which is
completely benol it's not just about her
looks she's a she's pretty but she's not
like a runway model she's not she's
she's just like a very pretty normal gal
singing perfectly Pleasant inoffensive
song
about totally ordinary things like
breaking up with your boyfriend and and
these Millennial women can find her very
relatable there's one moment later in
the movie that summed it all up for me
which is where Taylor set the stage I
mean amazing production value all of
these different set pieces different
eras different different characters that
she's taking on and in one she's in a
what seems like a magical wood and she
says look in my imagination I'm in
folklore I'm in an enchanted wood in my
imagination I'm not just some lonely
Millennial covered in cat hair binge
watching TV you know that's my that's
maybe that's my real life unlucky in
love I keep getting dumped but I'm still
young and single and cool and I'll keep
dating people like that NFL guy but I
you know I'm kind of lonely and I'm not
and really the thing that just gets me
out of bed in the morning is all of you
I just love all of you but I'm kind of
but in my imagination I could be so much
more this is an extremely famous
extremely wealthy extremely
successful rather pretty woman she is
one of the least relatable people on
Earth if you just look at the
descriptors that would describe her and
yet she persuasively argues that she's
just like you and she makes the whole
show about the audience at one point
Taylor leans over her piano and she kind
of jokes about how she's leaning she
goes why am I even leaning this way I
don't know whatever I'm just I'm just me
you know I'm just me I'm just being me
she goes I know that you're supposed to
play it cool you're supposed to but guys
I'm just telling you from the bottom of
my heart this is the greatest experience
of my life being on this tour and I'm
I'm sure she means it I'm not making fun
of her I don't think she's being
insincere it's it's an amazing tour this
thing sold out the tickets were
thousands of dollars each she sold out
everywhere
she now is a billionaire because of it
you know this is one of the most
successful music tours ever in history
she go and it just I know I'm supposed
to play cool but I just thank you so
much thank you for doing this for me and
and for showing up and being supportive
and just thank you and it's so simple
entertainers used to do that but for the
past 20 30 40 years
even our culture has been so infected by
irony and
apathy that that that kind of sincerity
is shocking and is refreshing
and really
resonates one time I was in Cuba I was
in Havana and I went to one of these
Ricky Ricardo kind of shows you know
babalo type thing with the dancing girls
and the drum players and what struck me
about it at first was the sincerity of
the performance these were trained
performers who took their job seriously
and who put a smile on their face and
they they just put on a good old style
show for you unlike most of of our
musicians today and our show people who
just they faint apathy they show up yeah
whatever man you know this one this one
I wrote this song for my girlfriend or
whatever who cares I don't know you
might not like it I don't care what you
like you know and even when they speak a
lot of the the modern performers they
speak in vocal fry you know it's like
they don't care man I'm cool I'm
apathetic in fact Taylor spoke to that
directly when she said I know you're
supposed to play but I just sincerely
I'm going to say on my voice with my
breath looking at you not a hint of
irony thank you for what you've done for
me I really appreciate it so refreshing
she keeps thanking the audience I think
sincerely for saying you let me do this
you let me explore different genres I
love one of my favorite lines of the
movie she says you you go out there and
you you allow me to just take all these
risks and explore these genres and I
thought you
know it's not a knock on Taylor Swift
she's great at what she does it's not a
huge amount of range here to the music
you know it's kind of like pop with a
country flavor to country with a pop
flavor to that's kind of you know it's
not um Miley Cyrus is Disney girl to
pansexual acrobat you know that's a
that's a huge
range with Taylor Swift she's much more
controlled she's much more disciplined
about that but even then she she
persuades her audience that that the
audience is allowing her to take all of
these huge risks when you want to
protect your data you've got to go to
expressvpn.com
YT as you know there are a lot of people
who want to look at what you are doing
online the government the isps the big
tech companies they all are digging into
your stuff and so you should use the
number one rated VPN on the market not
just according to me but according to a
number of outlets and authorities as
well that would be expressvpn head on
over there right now we've got all sorts
of great deals and promos if you are are
a listener and a viewer of this show do
not wait you got to go immediately over
to
expressvpn slm letter y letter T that is
expressvpn.com
slm YT today Taylor Swift is a lot like
Paul McCartney I like Paul McCartney's
music more than I like Taylor Swift's
music but they're similar in that you
can tell they are both just fanatically
obsessed
with making hits you think about the
Beatles John Lennon wanted to get some
political statement in or whatever
George Harrison wanted to play sitar and
do kind of weird Indian stuff Paul
McCartney doesn't want any of that Paul
McCartney wants to make hits that people
like and Taylor Swift I think is a lot
like that and so she just goes where the
hits are and even though she's very
disciplined about her range sometimes
she'll do a song that's kind of sexy but
even when she does a song that's kind of
sexy where she's kind of jiggling and
dancing and talking about like you
touching her and stuff even I I don't
know the names of almost any of these
songs but in one of them she she says oh
you know when we're together when we're
doing stuff late at night in my dreams
this is what it's like so she's doing I
don't know what the song is called but
it's this song that seems like if I if a
more vulgar artist were doing it it
would be like yeah baby and you're
touching me here and we're going in the
back room and doing whatever but for
Taylor Swift it's one degree removed she
goes we're we're doing all these kind of
sexy things in my dreams so it's just a
fantasy it's still kind of wholesome and
then of course you get that wholesome
image such that one or two sets later
she's changed costumes she's changed
settings and she's in this white
virginal dress and she's singing some
other kind of wholesome song then at
other times she delves into something
that you might even call a little a
little bit a cult there's this serpent
Motif that comes up through one of the
sets there's what looks like a witch
costume in a witch setting but it's it's
slightly elusive you know it's not too
on the nose
so she scratches that itch in the
audience she's extremely malleable from
the perspective of her character and the
reason she is the reason she can do that
is because she pushes everything onto
the audience her main move in the show
is to just point at the audience and
because she's in in a huge Stadium just
erupts in cheers and so and she just
does it with with her finger she always
is making it about them not about her
she's merely a vessel for perfectly
Pleasant pop and it works because it's
obviously made her a billionaire then
she'll get even more wholesome there's
some song about hugging people she says
I want a hug or I want to give you a hug
or something like that and so this was
obviously pre-planned but she goes up to
the stage and there's a little girl this
perfectly cast lovely I think it was a a
black girl but some at least vaguely
diverse and you know brigh eyed and
right out of Central Casting and Taylor
comes here gives her a big hug a little
kiss on the cheek the audience goes
totally crazy right on the line about
hugging someone and so that way she's
gone from country ballads to angsty
teenager to sexy upbeat song to kind of
funny upbeat song like the Shake It Off
thing to almost Mr Rogers she's saying
go give me a hug with the little girl
the she's she can just do anything
fairly persuasively so she like a true
entrepreneur she goes to where the
demand is it's not that she's got a
message that she's selling she's got one
kind of product and she's going to make
sure that you like that product she's
going to persuade you that that's what
you want she's going to figure out what
you want first and then she's going to
give that to you just you hear this with
all good salesman they say the key to
being a good salesman is you don't you
don't sell the customer what you want to
sell you sell the customer what they
want to buy and that's what Taylor Swift
does
the culmination of all of this is to my
mind not that interesting but it's not
for me
it's four predominantly white
predominantly Millennial women with some
little girls in there too and maybe
there were a few
guys at least guys who were a little bit
light in the loafers and even to that
point she was doing one of the numbers
and it looked like there was a either
transvestite or vaguely
LGBT inclined person or multiple people
on the stage but even then it wasn't too
much it was a little bit ambigu us it
was totally
inoffensive Taylor Swift is in that way
kind of like Bill Clinton or maybe even
Barack
Obama where you can see this person
speak and read into that person whatever
you want especially
Obama was a blank canvas no one really
knew anything about him he would brag
that he could walk into a room with a
hundred people who had totally different
views and he could persuade each and
every one of them that he was on their
side
Bill Clinton pioneered that kind of
politics in the for the
90s Taylor does that where Taylor
apparently says kind of crazy lib things
but they're not that crazy and she's not
that vociferous about it and I look at
her and I think she's kind of
conservative in a way this is why I
would give the movie just a little bit
of an edge on the traditional side
rather than on the liberal side because
even if she supports I don't know I
don't even know what political views she
supports but if she supports some LGBT
or some any other kind of some democrat
or something her character is
conservative she doesn't have crazy
piercings she doesn't have purple hair
she doesn't have
tattoos she's pretty but she's not some
dolled up cosmetically
enhanced supermodel she's just normal
she's normal and I think this is the key
to the success she's just a normal
person in a society that is is defined
by the abnormal that exalts
bizarre behaviors and desires and
fetishes and ideologies and and in that
Society where being weird is has become
the norm people are starved for things
that are sincerely normal and she's one
of them you just want a girl who's kind
of pretty who can who can she's more
than kind of pretty but not threatening
who can persuade you that she's just
like you to get up there and sing about
how she's heartbroken cuz her boyfriend
left her but that's okay she's going to
shake it off again it's not for me but
I'm not surprised she's a billionaire
see you next
[Music]
time